how did you become the cinematographer
on Tron I have no idea
I went for a meeting with the director
Steve list boga at the Disney Studios
I'm not quite sure how I got that
meeting or how it was set up but I think
it was from my other friends in the
business
I reckon they recommended me but then I
got into the office and it was almost
like I had the job before I even like
begin began the interview you know so I
have no recollection of being
interviewed for the job it was just like
well this is this is what we're doing
and you know let's let's go let's let's
get it together and do it yeah so there
wasn't much of an audition process there
but but there again at that movie
because of its technical challenges
there were they they were I don't think
they were greenlit totally when when I
took my meeting and got involved in it
so there were some screen tests and
different push the concept that Disney
wanted before the show moved forward and
so I was involved on those and so you
know slowly you know everything came
together and we got greenlit this got
greenlit and that got greenlit and then
finally we were making the movie so
there's a process how did it work with
the cinematography and then the effects
like how was that especially in the
early 80s
well there were three three aspects of
Tron there was the live-action and then
there was the CG animation and of the
the first CG animation ever ever used on
a movie and then there was stuff that
was created to be in the cyberspace
electronic world footage that was based
on live-action now that live-action was
you
everybody was wearing like black and
white suits and was shot in
70-millimeter and they took every frame
that we shot and they blew it up onto a
16 inch wide co2 earth and then those
were put under the animation stand and
shot with color gels and diffusion
filters and so it became an animation
process and there were a lot of things
that we had to do to make sure that when
the black and white photography was
blowing up onto these high contrast
cells that they would work in the
animation process and mostly to do with
having very very sharp frames because
the center called motion blur in
photography which is when something
moves in front of a motion picture
camera things blur and so for instance
if they had a line on their suit and
they were in motion if that lion wasn't
perfectly sharp it would just disappear
from the Codel if negative so we had to
have infinite depth of field we had to
have a very short shutter which meant
that every image was like perfectly
sharp you know and and all that required
a tremendous amount of light and the
fastest film that we could use and the
fastening on did the other thing to
create that depth of field we needed to
shoot at a very very high aperture you
know it's a lot of the stuff was shot
around f/8 and at 16 and excuse me f11
which required a tremendous amount of
light and in fact Burbank Water and
Power called the studio twice during our
productions that you're using too much
electricity we got a
kind of shut you down if you don't use a
little bit less so oh wow
we were welding with light on that movie
you know so they must have stay saw the
the usage from wherever they absolutely
do a triviality okay peaked and I could
tell where I was coming from and I said
okay how long was the actual shooting of
the film not not these other processes
but uh I think Tron I think we shot for
69 days and I think the the regular
live-action schedule because we shot up
in Lawrence Livermore labs up there at
their shiva laser lab and and we shot
set sets on stage so I think that was
about 225 days all that kind of live
action oh and the rest was this hybrid
black-and-white photography that was
later been going to be treated on the
animation stand as special effects
footage do you remember what it was like
to see the premiere to attend it no I
just
I remember the I remember the they had a
they had a black and white ball where I
I guess the the women wore white and the
men wore black and it was at the Beverly
Wilshire hotel and that was a pretty fun
event I don't remember the premiere of
Tron well maybe it was a good night then
maybe a lot maybe a lot of people they
know because the story of Tron is is
strange because you know if it was a
picture that Disney had hyped a lot and
then somebody came out in the in the
Wall Street Journal and said this is not
the movie that's going to save the
Disney studio and their stock dropped
like two and two and a quarter points
and
then there was the premiere of the movie
and one week later et came out so it
really kind of got eclipsed and then
then somebody else at the studio said
okay we don't want this we want to take
this out of distribution because we want
to release the DVD at Christmas you know
so when it came out I don't think it was
it wasn't really that successful but
after you know after the summer it
started to pick up its own pace you know
and then suddenly they they cut it off
to do DVD sales so then that's plastic
so it doesn't really make any difference
in there was those the big video discs
that you would kind of put in laser
discs yes I remember
yeah but also video tape I think as well
so how was that - probably be so
thrilled to work on something that's
groundbreaking you put so many days in
what almost 70 days of shooting time and
then additional and post or whatever and
then to have like a well-respected
publication is common just for whatever
the agenda maybe there wasn't I mean but
just kind of crush it well it must have
been a lot worse first even less burger
than for me you know but you know my
work had been over for a long time
because obviously there was a
live-action schedule that I was involved
in but the whole post schedule was about
a year so we're talking about a project
that I finished a year beforehand before
it before it was premiered so I do
remember the first time I saw the movie
was that the was at the Chinese Theatre
on Hollywood Boulevard and it was
supposedly projected in 70 millimeter
and
the projections had it out of focus the
whole the whole show note like I was
trying to go back and say it's a lot
shop is a lot better than us in there
but that's something you get used to is
like distant distribution of your
product is not always at the quality or
the you shot the movie end but now with
digital all that's kind of going away
and you know I think digital media is a
lot more I think it's a lot even the
chances would be seeing the way it was
shot or a lot better in the digital
world than having a print and a road
show at a theater you know and with a
with the projector bulb that the guy
doesn't want to run it at full voltage
because the the bulb will last a little
bit longer
no sir so yes I embrace the digital age
[Music]
you